-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Tom Holland.
Last time you were here,
right before the holidays,
we were talking about
you had not had time
and, obviously,
you're a busy guy,
to finish your Christmas
shopping for your family.
I know you're very close
to your family.
You always have at least
one brother with you
when you come here.
It's very nice to see him.
Did you get it done? Did you get
your Christmas shopping done?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you for bringing that up.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just honestly,
I'd finished the "Spider-Man"
press tour and I was so busy
and I was so tired,
that I just didn't do it.
[ Laughter ]
And that's terrible.
That's terrible.
I've told my family and they're
already in agreement
that next year will be
a double gift year.
-Oh, wow! So they're
basically -- Yeah, okay.
-Yeah, put your orders in now
and I'll sort you out.
Don't worry.
-So they're ultimately
patient with you.
They're not
too judgmental of it.
-No, of course not.
I mean, my family are wonderful
and they know how hard I work
and the traveling
and, you know, like, you know,
the press tours are tough.
It looks really glamorous
and it is very glamorous --
I'm not complaining,
but I am complaining.
[ Laughter ]
Because it's really tiring.
-That's the part that's the most
remarkable to me.
We always talk backstage
because people don't understand
that it's almost exactly as long
as it takes to shoot a movie,
especially a movie the size
of movies that you're making,
you have to go out and then talk
about them forever.
-Yeah. And, honestly,
I'm so sick of my own voice.
-Yeah.
-It does get to that stage.
We'd finished work the other day
and I bumped into someone
in a bar
and they asked me
about "Uncharted"
and, immediately, I just went
into press mode,
like "It's a movie
that ticks all the boxes.
It's funny. It's exciting."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Stop talking like that!"
-And then, at the bar, did the
manager come over and go,
"Back to work, Holland!"?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, "Uncharted" --
this movie came about
because you wanted to play
sort of a young James Bond.
Is that right?
-Yes. Yeah.
It didn't work out quite
as planned.
[ Laughter ]
-But this is that kind
of character.
-No, essentially, I just --
I'm such a big fan
of James Bond
and I, you know, I've loved
Daniel Craig's movies
and I just thought,
if they were to move on,
it would be really exciting
to see like how James Bond
becomes James Bond.
So I pitched this idea
for a movie,
which is kind of a stupid idea
where, essentially,
you wouldn't tell the audience
that it was a James Bond movie
until the end,
but from a marketing point
of view, that's a nightmare.
[ Laughter ]
Like that just doesn't make
any sense.
-And you would never be able
to keep that secret.
-No, mate.
If I got cast as Bond,
I'd be like,
"I am James Bond," tweet.
[ Laughter ]
But, no, Tom Aspinall
really liked the idea
and, you know, they've been
trying to crack the case
with "Uncharted"
for a long time.
You know, there's been loads
of different actors.
Mark Wahlberg, at one point,
was going to play Nate
and now he's old,
[ Applause ]
so he plays Sully.
-Yeah. This is sort of like
breaking Hollywood news,
that Mark Wahlberg is old now.
Is that what you're saying?
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
No, I've been saying that
on all the press tours.
It's been really fun.
-It seems like, yeah.
Mark Wahlberg seems like
a person that you would,
as a costar, that you would be
able to tease relentlessly
back and forth
because I would imagine
he gives it
as well as he takes it.
-Yeah.
You can tease Mark,
but he's also quite a scary guy.
-Yes, he is.
[ Laughter ]
-So like I have a security guard
who's one of my best mates,
but I only tease Mark
when Jack's around.
[ Laughter ]
I'll be like --
No, I'm not going to say
what I was going to say.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. [Indistinct] right now
if I was like,
"Well, Jack's not here,
but Mark is."
I'd be like, "Jack!"
[ Laughter ]
-We've talked in the past
as well about, you know,
this is another big film,
great action.
There's a stunt in this film
that I want to ask you about
because, obviously,
you're no stranger to stunts,
but I've never seen somebody --
You are in mid-air
and you get hit by a car.
-That's true.
-[Both] Yeah.
-Now, how do they bring that
to you as an idea
and then you just call
your stunt man right away
and say, "Bad news"?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I dunno.
It's one of those things where
this, for me,
as a young kid growing up,
the Indiana Joneses
of the world
was my favorite genre of film.
-The best.
-So, to do it myself
was really exciting,
but then, I had to do it
and I broke myself.
Like they tell you, "Right,
we're going to do this stunt
where you're going to jump
into the back of an airplane
and then you get hit
by a car out of the airplane."
And you're like, "Wow!
That sounds amazing!"
And then you shoot it
and you're on take 12
and like, "Can we go again?"
And you're like, "No!
I'm done!"
[ Laughter ]
But it was tough.
I was actually on set
on "Spider-Man,"
pitching the movie to Zendaya.
I was going through the film
scene-by-scene
and I told her that.
I was like,
"Oh, there's this great bit
where I get by a car
out of a plane and she's like,
"I have to stop you there.
What on Earth
is this movie about?"
[ Laughter ]
But it was fun.
It was a lot of fun
and the stunts is something
I've always really enjoyed.
I have two amazing stunt doubles
who I've worked with
for a number of years, now,
and we have a great little thing
going on where, you know,
our motto is that things
should look dangerous
while being safe.
That's not always the case.
You know, there's bangs
and bruises here and there,
but it's part of the job.
But, yeah,
being hit by the car --
My mum actually came to set
that day.
-Oh, wow. Did she know it was
Hit by the Car Day?
-No!
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And then, the next day,
after hit by the car,
was Drown in the Well Day.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-Mate, it was brutal.
-Yeah. I guess that would've
been awful,
if she like read the script
and said,
"I want to be there on the day
you get hit by a car
and I definitely want
to be there
on drown in the well.
-It's that thing for me like
whenever my mum and dad come
to visit set
is always the day
where I don't work.
It's always the day where I'm
in my trailer
and I have nothing to do
because they're like,
"There's a problem
with the sound stage,"
or they're
doing a different scene.
You're just,
"We need to wait for you."
So my parents were always like,
"Why are you so tired
all the time?
[ Laughter ]
Like what is wrong
with our son?"
And then, obviously,
coming to set on those two days
consecutively, I was like,
"This is why I'm so tired
all the time."
-Yeah. You're like, you know,
"You get hit by a car
out of a plane
and buy Christmas gifts
for the whole family."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Hey, man, it is always a full
pleasure to have you here.
-Thank you.
-Keep up the great work.
Thank you so much
for making time for us, Tom.
-It was a pleasure.
-You guys, that's Tom Holland.